This video is sponsored by brilliant.org
the first 200 people to click the link
in the description,
we'll get 20% off the annual premium
subscription.
Hey,
wise crack jared here and I promise I'm
not here to beat a dead Tauntaun.
As I'm sure everyone knows the last jet
I pissed off a lot of fans and wise
crack.
We've surfaced the usual rants.
Luke skywalker is suddenly a green milk
chugging coward.
Snow gets darth Maul before we know
anything about him.
Holos plan doesn't make any sense.
The Canto bight section is boring.
Raised parents were red herring,
marvel humor for days.
This is hops and of course lay hoppins
but we're not going to spend 15 minutes
fanboy rages.
Instead we're going to discuss how Ryan
Johnson tried to revolutionize star wars
but did so what went wrong?
Well,
to answer that and we'll need a little
help from a guy who in a roundabout way
is responsible for making star wars star
wars.
Nope,
not that guy.
This guy welcome this crack condition on
the last Jedi.
What went wrong and spoiler alert,
even though I already spoiled pretty
much everything now,
before we jump in,
if you will allow me to get a little
Meta on you.
The relationship between Kylo Ren and
Darth vader can be interpreted as a
commentary on the relationship new star
wars has with the original star wars
that you will never be as strong as
Darth Beta in the force awakens.
Kylo ren is burdened by the task of
living up to the legend of his
grandfather.
Just as the new series has the seemingly
impossible pressure of living up to the
legacy of the original trilogy.
Just as Kylo ren mimics darth vader by
dressing like him and using a voice
modulator,
even though there's nothing wrong with
his voice.
So too does the force awakens mimic a
new hope?
As many critics have noticed,
it's almost beat per beat.
The same movie.
This may seem like a stretch,
but the dynamic between smoke and Kylo
in the opening of the last Jed,
I furthers this meter reading as snuck,
tells Kylo to take off the stupid masked
and that he shouldn't even bother
anymore.
Y'All know,
just a child and then ren breaks the
mask a might as well go and throw Luke's
light saber off a cliff.
Oh wait.
Johnson is telegraphing to his audience
that this will no longer be a rehash of
the original trilogy.
The film will be a radical subversion of
the star wars formula for the new star
wars to live the old star wars must die,
but the time if you have to
with the last Jedi,
Brian Johnson isn't interested in
recycling old star wars.
He's interested in progress,
not only progressing the franchise
itself,
but the landscape of a certain galaxy
far,
far away.
In order to progress the franchise,
Johnson abrasively undermines the troops
and traditions that characterize the
previous fields.
Whereas Luke Skywalker,
the son of noble blood raise parents are
just degenerate.
Why knows nobody filthy junk traders.
So do you offer drinking money?
Our heroes are now janitors and
mechanics instead of politicians and
princesses.
Luke is no longer the idealistic hero.
He's a failed nephew,
murderer slash Slovenian philosopher,
Yoda.
It goes from symbol of Jedi.
Heidi two would be booked burner and the
jet I order kind of sucks.
Lesson two,
now that they're extinct,
the jet I or romanticize deified.
If you strip away the myth and look at
their deeds legacy,
if the Jeddah is failure,
hypocrisy,
Hubris,
that's not true.
At the height of their powers,
they allow.city
has to rise,
create the empire and wipe them out.
It was a Jedi master who was responsible
for the training,
ub Darth vader.
So you might be asking why on everything
that defined the previous films.
Well,
because turns out the events of the
previous films didn't really lead to any
progress.
After the collapse of the empire,
a nearly identical Nazi inspired
fascistic order has risen.
So clearly something is wrong in the
galaxy if this keeps happening.
So what's to blame for this reemergence
of evil?
Well,
Johnson seems to suggest it's are
inadequate conception of good and evil.
But wait,
start divisions between good and evil
are what the entire star wars mythology
has been built around.
It's the dark side,
not the dark nuance.
And here's where the movie almost gets
really smart.
As many of you may know,
George Lucas crafted the original
trilogy point for point around a book
called the hero with a thousand faces
written by Joseph Campbell.
The book sets forth a kind of universal
story structure from which myth stories
and literature all borrow,
which is why the structure is called the
monomyth,
but instead of simply recycling
Campbell's monomyth as seen in the
original trilogy,
Johnson uses it to complicate our
relationship with a dark side.
You see,
Campbell's monomyth is based on the work
of psychoanalysts.
Carl,
you wrote about ideas like the
collective unconscious and archetypes,
universal primordial images ingrained
deep in our psyche.
Those archetypes for Campbell informed
the kind of characters that keep popping
up in stories across continents and
cultures.
So let's talk about one of those
archetypes,
the shadow and how the last,
Jed,
I tries to radically redefine our
relationship to it.
For you and the shadow is the primal or
animal part of our unconscious that
tends to get repressed.
The dark side.
See where we're going with this.
In the monomyth,
this dark side usually gets embodied by
a character who represents the
shortcomings,
fears,
and anxieties of our protagonist.
Gollum is frodos shadow a stark reminder
of what he could become.
But if you really want shadows,
one o one look no further than darth
vader and Luke Skywalker.
Darth vader was once a powerful Jedi who
succumbed to the dark side for Luke.
Darth vader serves as a constant
reminder of what he could become if it
does not conquer his fear.
And Master has passions.
So confronting darth vader is more than
just a physical confrontation.
It's an emotional and psychological one.
It's why Luke spares darth vader's life.
If he were to strike him down in anger,
then he's lost the battle with his inner
demons.
But we're as the old star wars wants you
to conquer your inner demons.
The new star wars has other ideas in all
the films were meant to believe.
That balance in the force is desirable
for the good of the galaxy.
You refer to the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the force.
You believe it's this boy.
However,
the last Jedi suggests that the forces,
something that inherently promotes
balance.
When the darkness rises,
the force amplifies the light to balance
it out.
Darkness rises to meet.
I warned my young apprentice that as he
grew stronger is equally in the light
would rise if we're to believe snuck
here.
Wouldn't that mean that the inverse is
true than any powerful Jedi order would
be met with an equally powerful dark
side?
If so,
we have no choice but to read Luke's
criticism of the Jedi order as one that
blames them in part for the cyclical
rise and fall of these fascist empires.
While it's kind of ambiguous,
this logical conclusion seems to be
hinted at by Luke.
Yes.
The lesson that fourth not bombed the
jet.
I to say that at the jet I died a light
diocese bannock feel that
with episode eight the dark side is no
longer something to be conquered by the
valeant jetta.
I at the behest of the light side,
because that will make the force over
correct to achieve balance leading to
more amplifications of evil.
According to union analyst Robert H.
Johnson.
Not to be confused with Ryan Johnson,
we shouldn't think of our dark sides as
something to merely conquer and expunge.
Johnson says this,
active repression causes us to
accumulate the darkness,
which creates an ego split according to
his reading of Ume.
When you suppress the darkness,
you're forced to find a scape goat
project,
all your own ugliness onto them leading
to a never ending fight.
This is quite literally done in the very
way the original star wars is written
with Luke's inner demons projected onto
an evil space wizard.
Instead of maintaining this classic
distinction between good and bad,
both within our characters and in the
general plot,
Ryan Johnson tries to complicate it at
every step of the way.
As we see,
conquering evil with good hasn't done
much for the galaxy.
The empire is basically back with a sexy
new rebranding and snuck is basically
palpatine 2.0
in earlier star wars deek.
Good bad distinction is literally black
and white,
and thus the force awakens brings us
right back to where we started.
So to progress the franchise.
Ryan Johnson tweaks the basic youngest
formula.
If you suggested that we must reconcile
our dark side with the rest of our
personality.
Does the galaxy need to reconcile it's
dark side with the larger order of
things?
Oh,
US
consider Benicio del Toro's character
Dj.
Rather than upholding the traditional
distinction between purely good rebels
and purely evil oppressors,
he explores how even the good guys can
get caught up in the darker elements of
the universe as the galaxies very own
blackwater mercenary,
the cynical Dj sees through the false
divisions of good and evil.
At least you're stealing from them
bad guys and helping the good,
good guys.
Bad guys made up words.
Let's see who formally owned his own an
arms dealer made his bag selling weapons
to the back.
Guys
under good.
This marks the most morally ambiguous
moments in any star wars film when he
not only suggest that divisions between
good and evil are insincere and
unhelpful,
but complicates our understanding of the
rebellion as an infallible good.
Robert Johnson sees our traditional
understanding of the light and dark
sides as straight up dangerous.
He says that our inability to reconcile
with our shadow and therefore our
eventual scapegoating on to others will
inevitably end in violence,
war and racism for the last Jed,
I rather than the good guys and bad
guys,
there's a system at play his own machine
partner,
live free,
don't join.
It becomes the first star wars film to
explicitly critique the galaxies,
military economy and the exploitation
and animal rights violations inherent in
it,
which even heroes like Princess Leia are
party to then shelled us to test their
weapons.
So you might be asking at this point,
aside from being too ballsy,
what one wrong?
Well,
the movie goes out of its way to in both
form and content,
tell us that we must kill the past,
whether it be the past structure of star
wars films or the moral lens we
understood the previous films through,
then this happens.
It's time to little things.
Die,
smoke Skywalker,
Jed,
I the rebels,
let it all die,
right?
I want you to join me.
Ray is given a chance to end all the
dogmatism of the previous films and yet
she says No.
And from this point on,
it's all back peddle central.
Nope.
No,
you're still holding on.
All the things that we were convinced
need to be killed are reaffirmed,
tearing down the heroic archetypes
inherent in the mono myth.
Shampoo's burning advantaged with a
handful of my students slaughtered the
rest.
Layered blimps smoke.
But
it was me.
I fail cause I was Luke Skywalker chat.
High master
a legend.
Nope.
The legend of Luke Skywalker lives on
inspiring the galaxy once again and this
time as an added bonus.
It's a lie.
Gay Necessity to tear down established
orders that delineate the division
between good and evil.
It's time for the Jedi to end.
Nope,
not be the last gen I
desire to distance itself from the
established narrative structure of the
original trilogy.
Nope.
Strike me down in anger and I'll always
be with you.
It was striking to me.
Dot.
I will become all powerful than one
possibly imagined.
Get the jet I pass.
Nope.
Save the books.
It's not that movies can't insert ideas
and then ultimately reject them.
But usually the ideological shift
happens as the plot pushes our heroes to
reconsider their ideas.
In interesting and thought provoking
ways.
Instead Luke decides to reaffirm all the
antiquated ideas because he loves his
sister.
I guess other reversals are equally
perplexing.
Don't be a hero.
She was protecting the light.
Then she will see me like
until it's okay to be a hero and by this
point the film has made a
psychologically sophisticated case for
why ray should team up with Ren.
The old way doesn't work.
Jed Eyes are repressed as hell and we're
stuck playing a galactic game of Nazi
whac-a-mole fine.
We need a radical change,
which is literally what Ren seems to be
offering despite her faith in Rennes
essential goodness and despite Luke's
lesson that the forces beyond good and
evil ray hesitates.
Here's where ray and ren become opposing
stand ins for the films to potential
moral codes.
Ran is the realist who knows that the
rebels will try to impose the same moral
expectations on to ray as they did to
luke having become well acquainted with
his bad side and his good and wisely
calling out the folly of the false
division.
Ren is arguably closer to finding that
youngian balance than most.
He seems to be offering to ray exactly
what Robert Johnson and can say a person
should strive for recognition that the
ego and shadow are both part of a
person.
And what's more that one literally
cannot exist without the other.
Meanwhile,
ray represents the old moral code of
Star Wars.
The temptation to run away with her
swole new crush is ultimately overcome
by her desire to be the good jetta I a
morally pure infallible hero who
definitely isn't suppressing a lifetime
supply of darkness.
No surgery.
So if you're going to revolutionize star
wars,
great.
Want to reframe how we think about the
central conflict?
Cool.
But spending this time abrasively
subverting everything we love and know
about star wars.
Just do shrug and revert back to where
we started.
Nah,
less cool.
But what do you think wise crack is this
latest iteration of star wars
sacrilegious or a much needed fresh take
on the series.
Let us know what you think in the
comments and as always,
thanks for watching peace.
Now,
while the last jet I had its problems.
So to does my life.
Recently,
my social media account was hacked by a
troll and actual living under a bridge
troll.
He held my twitter captive unless I
could answer this.
Brain teaser from brilliant.org
supposed to people standing in place are
holding a rope firmly so it doesn't slip
through their hands.
Which of the two people can apply a
greater force on the rope?
The person was stronger muscles,
the person with greater mass,
or will they both apply equal force?
I was clueless until I checked out
brilliant.org
website that makes learning math,
science,
and logic fuel like an arcade game.
Personally,
I love their physics of everyday module,
which helped me get the riddle right and
now I have my twitter back.
Define more awesome puzzles and the
solution had to brilliant.org/wise
crack or click the link in the
description.
Not only will they email you the
solution for free,
if you're one of the first 200 people to
click on the link,
you'll get 20% off in annual
subscription.
That's it for today.
Going to go update my passwords.
Peace.
Y'All.